wholesome healthful surroundings like
these for children while their mothers
are at work this is not only an
act of giving for a community
investment in its own safety its own
future from which everybody benefits
safeguarding the health of a baby during
those first most perilous days of his life
and the health of his mother
during the time of her confinement
clinics to guard the health of every
individual knowing how important this
is to all the rest of us foster homes
for children who need the shelter and
loving care and guidance only a home can give
the visiting nurse sent as the community's
ambassador of Hygiene and health into homes
like this to combat illness or to assuage pay
mute agencies giving boys and
girls their chance to serve - on